it's a war for the surface world still
in the cards here's how Namor surprise
decision hints at so much more than you
realized warning there are spoilers
afoot being a technologically advanced
small isolated nation in possession of
an incredibly potent and rare mineral is
the kind of situation that can cause
friction with your neighbors in the case
of black panther or Kanda Forever This
description could be equally applied to
both wakanda and talocon both of which
have tremendous reserves of vibranium in
case you've missed out on the MCU over
the past decade vibranium is an
exceptionally hard to find resource on
much of Earth though both wakanda and
talukan have enough to forge and fuel
entire societies it does show up
elsewhere in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe notably in Captain America's
shield and vision's body it's beautiful
the vibranium atoms aren't just
compatible with the tissue cells they're
binding them of course a narrative in
wakanda Forever is kicked off because of
this resource which draws both reclusive
Nations into conflict talocon is led by
Namor a famous pragmatic anti-hero from
the comics talukan is an underwater
Kingdom that is essentially ruled by
Neymar and he becomes incense when the
CIA uses a vibranium detecting machine
that leads them directly to this
secretive Kingdom many more blames
wakanda for this trouble and gives them
an ultimatum find and turn over the
scientists responsible for the device or
the full Fury of talukam will be
Unleashed upon wakanda considering that
the major fight in Black Panther wakanda
forever involves wakanda and talukan
these two civilizations must have very
different opinions about the surrounding
world when you said we are doing open
wakanda to the rest of the world this is
not what I imagined wakanda within the
context of the MCU is slowly opening
itself more and more to outside Nations
while taloconus trades up hostile at any
territorial infractions at one point in
the movie Neymar offers shuri and her
fellow accountants of peace treaty and
Alliance in order to subjugate the rest
of the world Birds wakanda rejects the
offer that's the final battle between
Neymar and shuri comes to its
combination Shoei gains the upper hand
quickly realizing that vengeance is
taking over her heart shuri stays her
hand from slaying Neymar who then offers
to yield to shuri One initial
interpretation of this surrender is that
he's moved by shuri's offer for a truce
however Neymar later makes a comment
that both wakanda and salukam will need
allies in the battles to come which
hints that perhaps he isn't done with
his plans to wage war in the surface
world that can't be good so what is the
best way to explain Neymar's Newfound
capitulation to wakanda throughout black
panther I can't forever Neymar's primary
motivation is the preservation of his
people at the expense of all else maybe
he is simply establishing rules of
non-aggression with the one nation that
could theoretically bring ruin to his
beloved Homeland it's also made clear
that Neymar believes for Khan there will
be inevitably attacked for its vibranium
and turn to talocon as an ally doing so
would leave wakanda in debt to talukan a
debt that could be repaid by fighting
alongside them in other words Neymar
isn't the type of person to seek peace
unconditionally and there is definitely
a vibe that he has further plans
somewhere along the line whether he is
trying to remove wakanda as an enemy or
establish them as allies is still up for
debate but one thing is for certain this
won't be the last time MCU fans get a
chance to see Neymar whether he is an
enemy Ally or a mix of both is up to
Neymar himself he's always straddled the
line between villain and hero
foreign
[Music]